I think I think chefs and restaurateurs
are constantly fiddling with and
tweaking the degrees of formality and
informality that they put in their
restaurants and one of the things that's
really interesting to watch now is is
the ways in which different chefs and
restaurateurs both in terms of settings
and in terms of what they put on the
plate try to find some sort of perfect
sweet spot between formality and
ceremony and in formality and total
laid-back nests you know and the ways in
which they're trying to figure out what
are the bits of coddling and pampering
that that diners really really need and
that and that you want to hold on to to
to keep the restaurant experience as
it's always been and what can you
jettison and and for many diners
actually improve the experience by
jettisoning so this sort of constant
search for a perfect midpoint between
coddling and an utter utter in formality
is is is is not not so much a trend as a
preoccupation that I think we're going
to see worked out and and and thought
about and sweat it over for years to
come the whole farm-to-table movement as
it's called which is kind of over name
because we don't exactly have a lot of
farms you know right here in Manhattan
that the food's coming from but the
quest to bring people dishes and a menu
that is as reasonably seasonal and local
as it can be I think that's I think
that's here to stay and I think that's
going to become amplified in the coming
months and years not many restaurants
are going to be able to achieve that
sort of proximity to their food but it's
important to note like a lot of if you
look really long and hard at the menus
even at restaurants that claim to be
doing this sort of you know low carbon
footprint Alice Waters blessed you know
as organic as possible to the extent
that organic has meaning etc etc I mean
there are always there there are always
exceptions and asterisks
that come into play at the end of the
day when you want to give diners a
certain range of foods for instance Blue
Hill at Stone Barns which is often held
up as the model of this kind of approach
to food in order to serve a broader
diversity of things at any given moment
of the year it's using an enormous green
house on the property to essentially
kind of stretch out the existing seasons
and there are times there when you will
get a piece of produce that seems like
suspiciously ahead of its season or
behind a season and that's because
they've essentially kind of in bed
they're using another set of seasons in
this greenhouse so so so it's it's imp
this ideal is my point is this ideal is
not really possible for almost any
restaurant to achieve in a four season
climate like ours where there are just
kind of certain times of the year where
what the land would yield is not going
to be sufficient it's funny in winter I
see a lot of restaurants in Manhattan
still have a page of their menu which
says seasonal stuff and on it there will
be a lot of dishes using citrus and ways
that it's seasonal in terms of where
that citrus is coming from but at that
point the word local has exited the
local seasonal cuisine emphasis so it's
a difficult ideal to achieve and I think
what everyone's trying to do is get as
close to it as they can without asking
people to eat only root vegetables
during a certain month
well that's something that predates the
recession and that's something that is
about things that are larger than just
price I mean that that's about that's
about the way people want a dress and
feel and feel they have control over
their dining experiences so I don't
think the recession is going to affect
that in the sense that i don't think
that quest could be any more intense
than it is i also think that in New York
there are an astonishing number of
people with a lot of money and there's
there's an astonishing amount of money
from outside New York cycling through
the city so I i don't think the formal
restaurants are going to suffer as much
as one might just kind of in stay off
the bat think they would or I don't
think you can kind of use some sort of
economic ruler or barometer that's going
to affect restaurants the exact same way
maybe it would retailer something else
restaurants inhabit a peculiar universe
that doesn't that it isn't influenced as
directly as some others might be by by
economic indicators
I don't know I mean I think it's really
going to boil down in large measure to
how good certain restaurants are and the
degree of enthusiasm you know for that
moment I think restaurants that are
terrific and that have won the the
affections and the loyalty of their of
their of their diners are probably going
to be okay I mean their margins will
probably beaten into them and I'm sure
many of us affected by a recession are
going to look at that wine list in a
different way by a less expensive wine
on which the kind of markup differential
means a little bit less profit for the
restaurants so I think everyone will be
effective but I don't think or I hope I
mean I don't know I'm not an economist
so this really isn't a great question
for me to answer but I don't think or at
least I hope that restaurants the really
good restaurants are certainly not going
to be put out of business
that is that is so hard to say because
it would do it's it's a question that's
predicated on a sort of common sensical
assumption that that you know people are
learning more through writers like
Michael Pollan about about what it takes
to produce their food about the carbon
footprint that leaves and people are
approaching eating or at least
presumably they're approaching eating
with a higher degree of consciousness
because of these books and all that but
it's hard to know whether that
population of people is really at the
end of the day large enough to have a
big influence on the restaurant scene I
mean at the same time that that people
at we're growing more conscious of the
stuff already in certain ways and more
health-conscious in certain ways we've
seen a boon in steak houses in New York
over the last couple of years that
probably the probably the openings of
new steak houses over the last three
years probably outpaces any similar
three years before so for every so for
every move in one direction there's
there's this other universe of people
who are either impervious to it or don't
or don't have the same sorts of concerns
and it makes it really difficult to
predict where this stuff all ends up